these refugees count themselves lucky
they've made it to Germany and they feel
safe but being a refugee here isn't
always easy no other EU country accepts
as many asylum seekers as Germany the
trend is alarming says German interior
minister hans-peter freely from january
to September 74,000 194 people applied
for asylum in Germany that's an increase
of eighty-four percent compared to this
time last year proof says relief that
Germany is doing more than its share to
help dodgy stuff Germany's the country
that takes in the most refugees in
Europe bar none yes it also hides Amish
pizza but do those numbers really add up
not according to experts they say no
other European country is taking in more
refugees than tiny malta Swedish
companies mr. Preedy she obviously
hasn't done his math if you have to look
at the influx of asylum seekers relative
to the overall population when you do
that Germany only ranks tenth in Euros
adorable plots in countries like Italy
and Greece say they've been left alone
to cope with the recent wave of migrants
European rules say refugees have to
apply for asylum in the first you nation
they arrive in so central european
nations like germany are shielded but
now italy has started issuing visas to
refugees allowing them to travel freely
around europe the system is amend the
system is broken we need to reform it
ideally by using quotas to allocate
refugees al kuantan gentan or doc
Wharton so where do the people come from
who apply for asylum in Germany about
one-fifth come from Russia 18.2 percent
to be exact mainly Chechens refugees
from war-torn Syria make up about ten
point six percent eight point seven
percent are from Serbia and Afghans make
up seven point five percent with three
percent Somalia is the only African
country to make the top ten but if the
thousands applying for asylum each year
only a few are allowed to stay just
fourteen percent are granted refugee
status aamir 1.1 percent are recognized
political refugees thirteen percent live
here as tolerated refugees because it's
not safe for them to return to their
home country but nearly forty percent
are refused the remaining third retract
their application or go underground my
name the way we define asylum is much
too narrow economic refugees sounds like
an accusation though it really describes
a legitimate reason to migrate from the
home from the teeth poverty persecution
or war these people are all here for a
reason but only if you get to stay